you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with christina and matthew
but uh in the meantime let's see what's
on the front pages for you now the
sunday express carries an exclusive with
news that chancellor rishi sunak has
told the paper he's ready to do
everything in his power to help people
through the cost of living crisis
meanwhile cabinet ministers are turning
on the bank of england over rising
inflation with one warning that it had
been failing to get things right
according to the sunday telegraph
the observer leads with the government
being warned that many school buildings
in england are now in such disrepair
they are a risk to life
former health secretary jeremy hunt is
the lead story in the sunday times a
warning in a new book about the state of
the nhs and what he calls the cover-up
culture surrounding avoidable deaths in
hospitals
and the sunday people has the latest in
the row over serial killer levi
bellfield's plans to get married in
prison to a woman who's been visiting
him
and reminded that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by journalist
christina patterson and sunday times
columnist matthew syed welcome to you
both good to see you let's start with
the express and this is a feature over
pages four and five uh tory mps we read
are expecting an emergency budget in all
but name from rishi sunak tell us more
christina
well tory mps are certainly hoping for
an emergency budget and all that name
from rishi it's
it's very hard to know what actually is
happening because
things are being constantly
misinterpreted and there's clearly a
huge
rift essentially between boris johnson
and rishi sooner boris johnson wants to
just
hurl money at whatever he can to keep
himself in power and he is worried
rightly worried that the cost of living
crisis is about to make him and the
tories very unpopular cost of living
crisis actually puts it so mildly that
it sounds like something quite small but
this is
the biggest crisis in terms of costly
living that we have seen for decades
actually and um i mean this kind of
choice between heating and eating that
people are talking about
it's it's
no joke but also some people are not
even choosing between heating and eating
they actually
are beginning not to be able to afford
either usage of food banks and so on has
gone up enormously so boris johnson
essentially wants a great popular
um measure taken like a tax cut that he
thinks will boost popularity the trouble
is that rishi soon that doesn't want to
incur any more debt and the things he
could do that might actually help people
with the cost of living crisis which
would be targeting the poorest with for
example um
benefit increases or at least a reversal
of the benefit cuts that he imposed
after the pandemic
they're worried that that wouldn't cause
enough uh positive publicity to put it
baldly so i don't know where this is
going to end up but i very much doubt
that whatever they do is going to be
enough
to a solve the problem and b
stave off the unpopularity that's likely
to go with it well matthew the
chancellor has said that he's not ruling
out uh tax cuts it might very well be
something that he's looking into and
also he hasn't closed the door on uh
windfall tax so
these lines that that we're getting that
tory mps are expecting um
an emergency budget there might be more
to them than christina is suggesting
i i very much hope i mean christina's i
think completely right this is a seminal
moment for us as a nation uh the cost of
living crisis is going to be brutal
particularly for the least well-off
people in our society the poorest people
our society
and i think the concerns
uh that increases in welfare payments
and it's welfare payments that are the
most important here you can reduce taxes
as soonec has been talking about but
that doesn't help people uh who are not
in work and they're often the most
vulnerable
at times like this so it's got to be
increases in welfare jacob
uh rhys monks said this week that the
concern there is it might increase
inflation but i think that's a a
secondary issue the bank of england is
fundamentally responsible for inflation
it's the government
that has to take account of the
distributional consequences of its
fiscal decisions and this is a time to
step up and to show
creativity but most importantly
compassion and i think if the government
doesn't do that the public will see it
and the people who are least able to do
so will feel it and and feel it deeply
uh you mentioned the bank of england
let's move to the sunday telegraph
because we read that ministers are
actually turning on the bank of england
and uh complaining that they're not
getting things right christina
well uh tory backbenchers and ministers
for that matter are very good at
attacking people who are announcing bad
news i'm afraid they very often don't
like reality
as is evident from the consequences of
brexit and the northern ireland protocol
and the
uh you know problems that that has
brought to northern ireland and to our
relationship with the eu because the
fact is that there is an inflationary
spiral around much of the world at the
moment and i suspect that the uh
economists at the bank of england know
rather more about how to control
inflation than tory back benches and
some ministers do but i understand that
they don't like the figures the figures
are very very alarming inflation is
currently seven percent that's five
percent above the target of of two
percent so it is very bad news but i
think this kind of constantly i mean it
goes back to what michael gove said
during the brexit uh discussions leading
up to the referendum we've had enough of
the experts and unfortunately the
experts often know what they're doing
whereas uh the elected politicians that
know rather less so
i think it's a sign of their panic
actually because they're realizing that
this is something that they can't
control not just inflation but how they
deal with the consequences of inflation
so i i think it seems a slightly
childish thing to me to do but there's a
lot of lashing out at the moment and
this is just one example of it yeah so
the telegraph characterizing this is an
highly unusual attack one of the senior
ministers warned it has one job to do to
keep inflation at around two percent and
it's hard to remember the last time it
achieved its target matthew
well i think
having looked at that story though there
was some criticism from from lord
forsyth
[Music]
a thatcherite minister
uh i think from the john major years and
i i think the critique is that the bank
has indulged in what's called
quantitative easing
to support the economy you might
remember they did this initially after
the credit crunch in 2008 and
also
during the pandemic i mean this is quite
unprecedented as an economic policy and
i remember back in the 1980s there was a
view that uh quantitative easing
monetary policy the supply of money was
the fundamental determinant of inflation
and there was a letter uh back in i
think 2009 that it would undermine uh
western currencies i think it was a
difficult judgment for the bank of
england i i agree with christina
criticizing an independent
uh
group of people seeking to keep on top
of inflation is a risky thing to do for
ministers and to leak the idea that it
might be brought under the orbit of
ministerial control that undermines the
credibility of the bank
in the financial markets
so i'm not keen on what they've said and
i do think that it's a difficult
judgment and i you know i haven't
personally made my mind up about the
relationship between quantitative easing
and inflation it's a very complex and
convoluted relationship yeah so and one
minister a conservative mp actually
quoted here as saying that uh the
questioning the independence of the the
bank of england um so that's another
another road that might be traveled down
somewhat let's move on to the sunday
times um still staying with the economy
new pressure on sunac as one in five
pulled into higher tax bands christina
yes well obviously this is uh arguably
bad news for those who are pulled into
higher tax brands the prediction is that
because of inflation and also rising uh
wages which is good news clearly
more people one in five people are going
to be likely to be paying more tax and
that's in some ways bad news for them
but also very good news for them because
they'll be earning more and it's good
news for the inland revenue for hmrc
because they'll have more
more money to spend more taxpayers money
to spend so the only way in which this
is bad news for the government is
because people might feel that they are
paying more tax and because the
government want to be perceived as as a
government that cuts tax
of course if they actually want to be
perceived as a government that cuts
taxes it would have been helpful if they
hadn't increased tax more than any
government for for some years and that
is precisely what they have done
so um
again i think this is uh you know kind
of panic on the government's front that
they are
they can see that this is getting out of
control they can see that people
are really feeling the squeeze but i
don't think the people we should be
worrying about most in society other
people who are paying operate tax you
pay operate tax because relatively
speaking you are considerably better off
than the vast majority of people so i
personally don't think it's anything to
worry about but i can see from the
tories point of view they think it looks
like more bad news uh matthew we've just
got less than a minute on this section
but this this does point further to the
fact that we might be looking at tax
cuts from the chancellor isn't it
yeah i i think the worry is that with
the tax burden at its highest for what
is it 70 years
um and with because the thresholds
haven't been upgraded more people are
moving into higher thresholds um the
right that the thatcherite tories are
very worried about the reputation
of the party
for keeping taxes low uh which has been
eviscerated but of course there's a deep
tension within the modern conservative
party between those who want low taxes
and
um relatively low regulation and the red
wall tour is so called who are quite
keen on high taxation and this deep
tension
within the party i think is reflected
in the indecision to a certain extent of
the government at the moment
interesting uh matthew and christina for
the moment thank you we are going to
take a break coming up we cover this
story on the front of the times the
headline reads hunt says rogue nhs
requires major surgery
do stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
you're watching the press preview still
with me journalists christina patterson
and sunday times columnist matthew syed
let's have a look at uh the sunday times
and this story about jeremy hunt the
previous health secretary he was health
secretary for summer six years and he's
talking about a cover-up culture within
the the nhs that's failing patients and
staff christina
yes well um i think he's probably right
on this actually he's he's got a new
book out called zero looking at um the
aim of achieving
zero unnecessary deaths in a
post-pandemic nhs so that's the reason
for uh and i think he's given an
interview to sunday times coinciding
with that
and clearly the nhs is full of people
who have worked who do work and have
worked tremendously hard and even have
been put under often unbearable pressure
um over the past couple of years and are
now facing even more pressure as um
waiting lists i think i think something
like um
one in nine people in this country are
now on an nhs waiting list so it's a
very very challenging situation for nhs
staff and it's not generally the staff
who are to blame for what he's talking
about but what he's talking about is a
culture where mistakes are not uh
sort of out in the open it's not a
transparent culture and a culture that
is opaque in this way tends to be an
unhealthy culture i myself have had very
bad experiences of nhs care and
some years ago i did a big investigative
campaign in the newspaper i then worked
for the independent to find out why uh
why so many of us were getting very bad
care
so i and i and i also what i found was
that it was largely down to culture and
very often at senior level if you have
managers and very senior managers who
want to cover things up
then people don't feel able to uh
to to tell their bosses when they've
made mistakes it's a punitive culture
and
it's an unhealthy culture so i think
jeremy hunt is right having said that he
was in the job for six years and that
should have given him plenty of time to
turn things around
and he also uh reveals how civil
servants in the department of health and
social care tried to stop him reading
patients letters of complaint and even
told him he couldn't send apologies to
families he says there were meetings
held behind my back to work out if they
could dissuade me from such a thoroughly
dangerous idea so not just within the
nhs but uh within within government also
matthew
yes this is a really brilliant book i i
i read it
a few months ago actually i got an
advanced copy it's a topic i've thought
a lot about some somewhat like christina
and there's no doubt at all that the nhs
has a lot of people within it it's a
huge workforce i think 1.3 million many
vocational dedicated
professionals on the front line very
busy difficult jobs but when something
goes wrong this is an opportunity to
learn to analyze the error so that
reforms can be put in place to ensure
the same mistake never happens again
some industries do this extremely well
like aviation which has a deep
continuous learning culture all near
misses analyzed all accidents
excavated through the black box to make
sure that reforms are put in place but
in healthcare professionals on the front
line are scared about being honest
because they worry about being blamed
struck off
in extremists put on trial for culpable
homicide so that creates a cover-up
culture but there's an additional
element too which is that because in my
view the nhs has become something of a
quasi-religion
uh a sacred cow there's a tendency to
close ranks because it's almost more
important to defend the reputation of
the nhs than to deliver the learning
that is so imperative
and hunt was secretary of state for
health for a while but i worked with him
on some of the reforms that he did put
into place we were confident that would
make a difference i think some of them
have made a difference but turning this
juggernaut around is extremely difficult
and i think uh this book i hope very
much will go some way to opening eyes to
what remains a very big challenge but as
you say many of these issues occurred
during his watch christine i think we
just got time to get your view on this
story in the express and it seems that
the maneuvers are on the way in that
secure stammer gets a fine
well it's understandable after his shock
announcement this week that he would
resign if he got a fine frankly i don't
think he really had much choice after
um in my view rightly impugning the
integrity of the prime minister for his
extremely uh casual and lackadaisical
attitude to getting fined i think he had
to um mark himself out in some way and i
think if he gets a fine he does have to
resign so of course people are lining up
i think the positive thing on this run
is that there are lots of very good
people in the wings well not in the
wings and a shadow cabinet actually
people like lisa nandi and yvette cooper
and rosina allen khan
so i i do think um i don't think it
would be a disaster if kirst farmer
resigned and apparently the the
candidate that the tories are most
frightened of is lisa nandy who i think
is excellent which of course means that
if the tories are frightened of her
she's the one that labour should
probably go for because she's very
quickly because we're running out of
time matthew can you give us one name
i'm not sure i'm not sure all right okay
we'll have to leave it there matthew and
christina thanks so much